تشتهر دول الخليج العربي بصناعه العديد من
انواع الحلويات نتعرف على اشارها الجيمات
وهي من الاطباق العربيه المشهوره في مختلف
دول الخليج خاصه خلال الشهر رمضان ويتم
تحضيرها في المناسبات عديده بعد غمرها
بشراب السكر
الخنفروش وهو نوع من انواع الحلوى
الخليجيه التي يتم تحضيرها على شكل فطيره
بنكهه الزعفران ومن المعروف انها تؤكل
طازجه دافئه يمكن الاستمتاع بها بعد غيرها
بشرب العسل او تناولها بدون اي اضافات
الكليجه وهي عباره عن اقراص كعك مصنوعه
بالدقيق ومحشيه بمكونات مختلفه منها سكر
او التمر او دبس التمر او العسل او حتى
المكسرات
مصابيب بالعسل
حلوى تقليديه شهيه يشبه بشكل كبير البان
كيك تتميز بمفاق مميز وبالقيم الغذائيه
العاليه لمكوناتها كما انها سهله التحضير
معصوب بالموز والقشطه يعتبر من الحلويات
الشعبيه المميزه للمطبخ السعودي واليمني
وهي من الحلويات التي من السهل تطبيقها
ومقاديرها سهله ومتوفره في كل منزل